In Britain, Prime Minister Theresa May called off a crucial vote in parliament...
...on whether to approve or reject her Brexit deal with the European Union.
In Morocco, a group of more than 150 nations adopt a global pact...
...meant to improve the way the world handles the flow of migrants,...
...despite a string of withdrawals driven by anti-immigrant populism.
In Poland, about 50 protesters interrupt the US delegation...
...sent to the COP24 climate change conference by US President Donald Trump...
...to promote fossil fuels and nuclear power.
In the US, Secretary of State Mike Pompeo...
...hosted Senegal's Prime Minister Mahammed Dionne at the State Department,...
...where they signed the Joint Declaration Challenge Corporation,...
...five-year, 550-million-dollar Senegal power compact.
Finally from Japan,...
...prosecutors have formally indicted former Nissan chairman Carlos Ghosn,...
...another Nissan executive and the Nissan Motor Corporation itself...
...for underreporting about 44 million dollars of Ghosn's income in financial filings.